islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes the quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can
[Music]
trust or praise his glory and gratitude
belong to him um so we're going to start
off now and um i want to make a few
things clear so we're just on the same
point inshallah
um is that firstly uh i'm not going to
be
muting because that would be unfair um
if i'm not mistaken he can correct me
that he did this kind of with daniel
hakikachu um he might have his reasons
whatever but i'm not going to mute but
we're going to listen to him as well
inshallah
one thing that's really clear i just
want to make clear as well is that um
this is not a debate because my debate
challenge with apus was that it's going
to be face to face that's that's
condition that i've set we'll come to
that later of why that didn't happen etc
we'll come to that later that's a whole
different topic uh this is a challenge
yeah which is an open curse so because
this is exactly the thing that we
um what i challenged apostle he agreed
on we're going to start off with that
that is my opening uh statement if you
want to say i'm going to pass it on to
apus i'm not going to interrupt him if
there's anything that he would like to
say before we start the mobile um
he can talk listen to
sure sure um so i i want to say first
off i explained to everybody here
already what we
were supposed to do initially was to
have a debate
uh i agreed to an online debate alidawah
insisted on a face-to-face debate
insisted that we do it in america then
said for some reason that he cannot come
to america because he has can take the
vaccine and he's against vaccines and
all that so we are supposed to have this
little curse fest today because
apparently i am i actually know that
islam is true and i'm a liar and we are
supposed to expose that today which is
which i find very funny now i made a few
conditions to alidawah before i agreed
to do this first off i said
i agreed to do an a curse during our
talks
only under the condition that you also
agreed to the debate conditions that's
what we originally said so
he would come to america we would have a
debate on islam and i would then uh also
engage with him in this little curse
fest now that didn't happen but i still
made a compromise and still say hey you
know what i'm okay with it i i will do
the whole uh
childish curse thing where we ask the
imaginary guy for um curses and all that
but i also said as a condition since i
make a compromise i have uh three
conditions and one of them is that i ask
you five questions and you must answer
them uh directly that is that is what i
said so um
i would like to do that before we go on
with the curse but first of all i want
to ask alidab a very a very uh simple
question
just because i'm curious this is not
part of the questions i'm just curious
and i'm sure everybody else is also
curious who's not familiar with islamic
culture and all the you know childish
nonsense and superstitions surrounding
islam what exactly does alidawah expect
from this little curse fest what exactly
does he think will happen what exactly
will that uh prove to him what does he
think the outcome of this will will be
can i talk
okay good
okay so like i said before we're going
to come to why did they the debate
didn't happen
after the curse yeah now let's make
something very clear
alhamdulillah
every chapter of the quran
starts with bismuth
no it doesn't
yes except with chapter except uh
chapter nine which is totally
good yeah so allah talks about are you
trying to test my knowledge here no we
have to of course
that's the definition we're gonna come
so every single chapter of the quran
starts with
except for
so allah talks about allah's mercy
and talks about many ways etc turning
back to him et cetera so when somebody
persists
on this belief now this believe there
are disbelievers who allah told us
those who do not fight you and kick you
out of your households allah does not
forbid you from being kind and just to
them so a disbeliever you do not put
them into the category of
a general category there are those who
do not fight you and want to kick out
your houses etc yeah so
therefore
when you
tell somebody that you are lying
when somebody has done for readers on 50
videos and you ignore them so allah
subhanahu talaha says okay if you after
evidence is brought forth you persist on
disbelieving then it's very simple we
are so certain and sure of our religion
allah says
61 that you bring your children we bring
our children you bring your family we
bring our family and we do an open curse
now the reason we're doing this is
because from my perspective just to
clarify is because islamophobia when
somebody is an islamophobe yeah like for
example you have isis isis when they
come and speak and say certain things
their foot soldiers take action and kill
innocent non-muslims on the road and the
same thing happens with the islamophobia
industry when they utter certain things
and you have individuals like the one
who carried out the new zealand
christchurch attack you have people who
take matters into their own hands and
see islam in the muslims as their
enemies and take the matters in their
own hands by massacring 51 people so
therefore when somebody like apos who
has done videos where his following is
like this you know general people as
well but also those who have a anti-hate
and they have a hate towards islam
they take the matters in their own hands
my wife when she's walking down the road
when her hijab is ripped off when i am
walking down the road with a beard or a
foe and somebody tries to run me over
and i'm not saying this happened to me
i'm saying these things that follow this
is a person who is outright directly or
indirectly calling for the
dehumanization of muslims especially
somebody like apos who has done a video
mocking the death of pilgrims
pilgrims who have no weapons in the
treaty of hodeidah when they were going
to makkah they had no arms innocent
individuals who are going to do
pilgrimage and this individual here
apus mocks the death of these
individuals you have dehumanized muslims
to a certain level where individuals who
watch your video i believe the
individual who carried out the
christchurch attack if he was to watch
your video would he say hmm
i changed my mind about muslims or hmm i
think i should carry extra bullets
that is the reason why i'm doing the
open curse because you are an individual
who i believe indirectly have caused the
life of innocent muslims i'm not saying
directly you do not go and say go out
and kill muslims so that is the reason
why we're doing the curse just to
clarify does that make sense
sure sure uh thank you for the preaching
session it's okay
are you okay no i i i want to ask you um
something in return to that just so i
can give a response to
that as well i know what you're gonna
say about uh i'm sure you have watched
uh
many of my videos you've posted about me
for weeks now where you'd uh post about
all the stuff that i talk about in my
videos are you aware that i uh posted
many videos including one that is
dedicated in which
i explain that i do not hate muslims
that i find it wrong to hate muslims and
that i condem uh violence and
discrimination against people are you
aware of that
can i answer
sure yeah just i'm just asking so i
don't want oh yeah
and it's the interview
so i confronted many people i'm not
someone that's in my bedroom i don't
stay in my bedroom like a keyboard
warrior let me make a screenshot that's
the one issue that i had with you you're
in your little bedroom face to face
because tommy robinson britain first
paul golding avi yemeni
the list goes on i can't face the face
yeah i don't see it in my bedroom
another like tommy robinson yeah these
individuals say the same thing you know
what they say to me ali i've got an
issue with islam i've got issues with
the muslims well i'm like hold on a
second mate
andrew's brevit who carried out the
another massacre yeah um um i think it
was sweden if i'm not mistaken yeah in
that country in his manifesto if i'm not
mistaken he also mentions iron hilsi
yeah and if i'm a mistake and tony
robinson was also mentioned along those
lines when these people and and also my
i want to see my local mosque in
finsbury park where my in-laws stay my
in-laws a man drove a van into the into
muslims yeah this man was inspired by
tommy robinson now you go to tommy
robinson which is now uh classed as one
of the 20 terrorists in the uk by name
has been officially announced by the
police
terror unit he says the same thing he
says look man i always say muslims are
my friends i joke with muslims this that
that man you are the same scumbag when i
confronted you you couldn't even bring
one verse this tony robinson by the way
yeah so i say the same thing and he says
exactly what you said earlier i do
videos i clarify i'm not a preacher but
that guy driving the van didn't say
tommy was telling me he muslims okay he
went directly to kill innocent people
and one person died so you have blood on
your hands
indirectly or directly of the answer can
you answer the question well that's good
question
can you answer the the question that you
never you know i did i did no are you
aware that i made such videos and that i
said yes i i just repeated it and i said
completely against hating muslims okay
okay good yes
but i'm saying that doesn't justify it
because tommy robinson is a terrorist
now label is understand i understand uh
did do you know if i ever made a video
or if i ever said that it is justifiable
or okay to
uh kill or punish uh muslims or people
who convert to islam
categorically you have not ever said in
any video that you should go out and
hunt or kill muslims but again the
problem if you allow me to elaborate a
problem
that was not the question though my
question was did i ever say anywhere
that it is okay or acceptable or good to
to to kill or to approach or to heart
can you hear me or people who convert to
islam yes you didn't answer the question
please okay can you hear me
yes i can
then how could you say i didn't answer i
just answered it because you said i'm
doubting them like no content this and
that so oh no no i said i'm testing the
mice because i said you did not ever say
that
okay
okay now ask now can we can i ask you
two more questions
you're going somewhere else
i'm responding to you i'm responding to
i'm responding to the thing did you or
did you not make a video i'm going to
give you a last chance
in which you said that people who leave
islam should be executed
this we're going to come to look i'm
telling you you know what i would come
to that what i'm saying now is we have
to do the mubarak i have very
categorically and clearly said that
islam has a law and legislation that
applies capital punishment for people
like you but guess what i've got a
present for you a prison for you're
going to laugh
let me quickly respond to your preaching
because i didn't i didn't talk i didn't
talk as long as you did okay let me
quickly respond to your preaching so so
you preached lengthily and said that
people like me because we talk about
islam are somehow to be blamed for
indirect or direct violence against
against muslims
but as it stands i
explicitly always oppose hating and harm
and violence and i have never advocated
for it on the other hand aledawa has
never ever made uh such a categorical
you know opposition or condemnation of
violence against people for their
beliefs and ideas and all that on top of
that he did make a video in which he
explicitly said that people like me who
leave their religion should be executed
and that he's proud of that but i am the
one who is indirectly uh responsible for
taking people's lives okay can i speak
ask me
go ahead you're gonna make me cry there
i'll be honest i watched titanic
but it wasn't that emotion that's what
you just said there i'm gonna start
crying oh can you pass me a tissue
please i need the tissue right now you
get that okay so let's just get this
right guys yeah dramatic ali tawa
please
do you see me crying do you see me do
you see me sad anyways
anyway look i'll listen to you that's my
turn yeah
now we're going to go to the mobile this
question that you asked
remind me we're going to come to it's
just i don't want to dive it off what
you said i'm going to make that
categorically clear but i know you're
diverting so i need to get you back on
track yeah now let's start off with the
mobile hella
and then we can slowly go on to ali
wants me this that and all these kind of
horror movies yeah you're probably
watching paranormal activity yeah okay
so and before we do that i've been
watching you yeah i've been watching you
who says it should be anybody's innocent
individuals to be killed be there a
mustache or not a mustache
well we'll come to it we'll come to
we'll come to it that's
just give me one answer i innocent
let's start just give me just one word
i'm not going to do nothing just one
word am i innocent according to you
no we know no so what do you say
innocent that doesn't mean anything
because i'm not innocent let me know
when you're ready
well i i have to ask you the five
questions so do you agree again uh i can
already know about it let me show you
and i understand i understand
what i'm saying is
you take it okay i want to remind you
you know
you agree once more that you will uh
answer five questions that i will ask
you
let me know
fine i have the screenshot of you
accepting the conditions anyway i'm
ready
okay good i'm ready okay thank you thank
you so much
fest everybody whoa it's gonna be party
time yeah chris fest so apus
this is in you're invoking it's a dua
you can put your hands up or you can
however you would like to do it
invoke the curse
of god or you're close to the christians
the christian apology apologist now or
you can ask the father the son and the
holy spirit it's it's up to you yeah
maybe you'll get your donations that go
a bit up yeah i'll ask allah yeah if you
want you can ask the trinity
because you're close to the christians
yeah david will be happy i will ask the
arabian god of the country okay so this
time is yours i'm going to give you
however you like it's 31 let me just get
one second
one second okay you got it's 8 31
um you can go
and you have your time
or do you want me to go ahead right now
with the president
sure um since it has not been exactly
yesterday how it should be done uh i
will uh i would like to ask uh allah the
almighty supposedly almighty god for
a curse that will be very specific i
don't think it's too much to ask he's
almighty he can do whatever he wants
let's do this
so
dear
allah who is the arabian god can you do
can you do this no i i i can do this how
about that how about that like this
okay this is how i pray to allah
you can pray what however however you
want anyways yeah he doesn't wow he
doesn't he's an ex-muslim and he prayed
like this yeah no i pray like this allah
arabian god of the kaaba
who took over the
place of the polytheists and who sent
his prophet mopus
dear allah i ask you if you are real and
if islam is true and if i am lying about
islam if i am lying about islam if i am
wrong deliberately
then
please right now
take my life within the next 10 seconds
within the next 10 seconds okay now
that's good now guys
did i stop you and did i dive in
okay wait for 10 seconds okay let's wait
10 seconds are over fine
there's two
guys check this out okay can i speak
i'm pretty sure allah will be okay with
this he doesn't have to he doesn't have
to wait for us to finish okay okay um
everybody you're seeing this right you
see the results i'm not dead
i'm alive
just let me know when you're finished i
don't interrupt you let me know sure
sure go ahead go ahead
okay good yeah sure now guys this is how
he fell in my trap
i got a surprise for you
what is it okay now this is where you're
going to get nervous you're going to
need that drink make sure you don't
drink it because you're going to end up
talking on it now
just get to the point
do you not claim you're an ex muslim
yes do you not claim that you know about
the mubarak one second
right i know where this is going okay
let's just not claim that you know
everything about islam
is actually done
that you as a practicing muslim yes
let's give that another tip we've got
two ticks offer not bad okay
do you not claim you know more than 90
percent of the muslims
yeah i'm not sure about 90 it might be
95 but sure around the world make you
99. yeah how about that i wouldn't say
99 no okay 95 95 is okay i'm happy with
that no that's let's say i'll i'll be
i'll be okay higher it goes better for
me so you said you are more you know
more about islam than 95 of muslims yeah
yeah okay yeah maybe sure okay let's
give that another check now we've got
1995 i don't know i have to think about
this but sure
yeah six are better than zero ticks
now sure
that's the next muslim who is practicing
who knows more than 95 percent of the
muslims
who didn't he know
are you guys ready
wouldn't he know that mubarak
cannot be done with an atheist
oh really
yes
one second one second do you not know a
mubahala is ibadah
i'm sorry do you not no it's it is a dua
yeah sure okay because because muhammad
himself offered it to people who believe
in god
we pray to our twitter what is
it's a form of worship worship oh really
i never knew that asking the
supernatural being for something is
worship
who would have known that
you can't do look
about it in the quran is with the
christians
and there's another verse which talks
about the music
you came here and you went with it like
yeah i will do it no problem and now all
along i was like oh my gosh i'm waiting
for this guy to come and say ali i'm an
ex-muslim who used to be practicing you
can't do mubarak with an atheist who
doesn't believe forget being a muslim
logically how are you calling up to
hello uh
who's anybody who are you calling out to
this is why i'm telling you you're
absolute ignorant you're a five star
grade a ignoramus fool
straight up
now that is done and we that was that
was i i couldn't believe i was expecting
you to come and say ali you can't do
mubarak and you know what he did you
don't even know the word you just went
and searched it up anyways this is done
this shows again it's the 17 year old
boy after that girl slapped you up the
17 year old boy actually humiliated you
now again again apos your track record
is crazy it's crazy above you've been
smashed up by everyone but anyways that
shows how ignorant you are you don't
even know what dua is and let alone you
know mahala cannot be done with an
atheist are you that jahil
are you done
are you done yes i'm done i'm i'm done
with it okay
everybody everybody look at his face
everybody everybody do you see do you
see the
stupidity here that's going on a muslim
comes out
and challenges me and challenges me to a
mubarak a
a a a an invocation
to allah to curse us uh under the
implication implication that i am a liar
and that i know that islam is true which
is why he challenges me to ask allah to
to curse you
so he challenges me
i accept it i say fine okay let's see if
i am indeed a liar or not and he's like
see you are so ignorant you actually
accepted my challenge exactly exactly
i mean you ask me
as somebody who is an alleged liar who
actually knows that islam is true to
speak to allah and ask for his curses
and i accept it despite knowing that i
don't believe in the supernatural and
that that i cannot engage in worship
just to show to you how idiotic it is to
ask me to do not ask allah for a curse
and then he says that i am the ignorant
one yes did you know this is what we are
dealing with this is the intellect
i shouldn't challenge you to a debate i
should challenge you to an iq test
this is this is the embarrassing
cringeworthy
quality of muslim apologetics
look look any muslims that's watching
this they know exactly what happened
i'm done with that we'll move into the
next yeah i'm done with that you said
that you know how can you come to your
own part you said that you know okay
this is my party you're waiting for it
we're gonna do the after party in a
minute yeah so did you did you say you
know that
you can't do it
with a native did you say you know that
i know that i cannot ask allah for
something technically i just can't
pretend okay what do you think what do
you think okay did you say you know that
you could have not done it but you just
done it is that what you said i know
that i cannot i know that a mubarak is a
communication to god i cannot
don't get that twisted and what is that
and what is that communication no my
friend communicating
a dictionary what i'm saying is this did
you say you know that you couldn't
yeah sure
okay where's the evidence
you said you know what's the evidence i
don't know i have to go i have to go
into my uh interview
i need to go into my brain and pick out
the pick out the knowledge
that i knew i can't do that which is
which is why i have to bring it down if
you don't have it
is this your logic is this your point is
this how you're supposed to argue in a
debate what is this what you're going to
go into in a debate as well if you don't
know how ridiculous you look right now
if you don't have a brain where'd you go
where do i where would i go i don't know
probably uh go uh back in time and
search the invisible world for evidence
that i actually knew that i cannot do
this just to prove to alidawah how how
he was right or how he was wrong do it
you know what this tastes better in real
life when watching a video how stupid
you are about in real life you know we
need to like you know when you see
something on tv but then you experience
yourself it's like damn like when i'm
watching you i'm like bloody hell you do
you do you actually do you actually
think you have made a fantastic point
and that you like that you look like the
smart one here anyway do you think that
do you think you made a fantastic point
today
fantastic is not the word it's is it
another word
okay
do you think you made a brilliant point
today
and i accepted it just to show to him
how ridiculous it is that an atheist
like me asks allah for a curse yes and
he says that that just exposes how i and
how ignorance
you are you don't need to be a muslim as
an atheist you could say to yourself
logically i don't believe in a god how
can i go and ask for the curse of
something i don't believe you don't need
to be a muslim a little child you're not
17 year old boy who smashed and slapped
you up yeah
go to them they will see you brother you
know you don't do you believe in god no
i i don't know how are you going on a
platform to ask
the curse of god yeah exactly that's
exactly that's the point that's why i'm
saying how challenging it is
in fact in fact look i have been live
streaming this before we before we met
and during that live stream i told my
own audience how stupid it is of you to
ask me to do this challenge go back in
our stream right now
people only see how idiots hello it's
stupid but i'm gonna do it anyways i
don't know yeah
i don't believe it but i'm gonna do it
anyways i was an ex-muslim anyways you
know why i'm dressed up like this
because isn't that how you dress up all
the time because you want to look
i'm going to compensate for it yeah i'm
going to your funeral that's why i'm
just like oh oh
i'm dead
he killed me he killed me with his
brilliant words and his amazing
vocabulary and his wonderful voice i
loved don't we all love the voice don't
we all love to hear alidawah do we all
love to hear him and we are so proud of
that
you said it might be a placebo effect
like you said it was working but it was
a placebo effect it was working but it
was a piece of placebo
no no no no no i don't need to there's
you can't do it you don't understand
that's stupid you cannot do it you're an
atheist you can do it dumbass you you
clown you can't two people have to do it
you are not qualified okay fine
okay i did it i did it anyway i did it
anyway exactly now you do it since you
challenged me to something now you
should do it come on do it listen listen
come in let's do it
come here
stability instability is this
[Laughter]
can you ask allah to uh curse you if you
are a liar you know what i'll do you
know what i'll do yeah i'll make a dua
this man either guide him to islam
or deal with him the way you deal with
him
or silence him the way you befit i
personally would want allah to deal with
you but
allah there's enemies of islam who have
come to he's come back to islam or
accepted islam guide him if he is not
deserving of guidance or blames it
blames you
allah knew they got recycled by that
girl allah guide into islam or deal with
them i mean that's all i can say
guys i have to tell you i have to give
you a secret no dawah keeps referring
what keeps referring to a girl
a few days ago who called me as a girl
although privately he admitted to me
that he knows it's not a girl it's
actually a guy but he keeps referring to
her to him as a girl just so he can make
a point he's deliberately lying and i
can demonstrate okay honestly
what happened there boy or girl it
sounded like a girl to me boy or girl
did you haven't your no having your own
people haven't your own people told
do you know
do you know that that is some that
that's that that's actually a god have
you been told
what do you know that we're talking
about you know it's actually a guy you
know why are you nervous you're anxiety
do you know it's actually a guy a girl
or i don't know if he's a girl or boy
yeah okay do you know it's actually a
guy how do you know how do you know
their girl how do you know i'm asking
you did you know it's actually i don't
know how did you know it's how do you
know the pronouns do you know that it's
actually a guy how do you know
do you know that it's actually a guy
yeah yeah
he does he does and i can demonstrate to
you that he does it
but he's lying even to his fellow
muslims let's go to chapter 49 we talked
about what um i said let's go back to
i'm reminding you that apparently i said
what apostasy let's talk let's talk
about that now because you're finished
that's done this is i want to ask you
five we need to come to my five
questions
i have not agreed this is not excuse me
hey hey
did you agree or not hey did you agree
or not did you agree or not that we will
that i will ask you five questions and
you will respond to them you agreed to
that you explicitly agreed to that okay
you speak last week you explicitly
agreed to that i have the message right
here i showed it earlier before i stream
i said yes i said yes i will accept this
under the condition that you accept
three conditions the first one is i will
ask you five questions and you will
answer the second one is you will call
me a positive prophet on the stream the
third one is you will not mute me you
accepted the five questions and you
accepted the uh the the not muting you
didn't accept the other one is that true
okay can i speak
just answer the question is that true
why do you always have to give me
is it true
can i speak just just answer the
question well of course i'm going to ask
the question i know you get irritated
i know you oh [ __ ] i know
different story yeah okay he said to me
free conditions now guys i think before
we go into the whole apostasy thing
let's make it clear of the debate how
did this whole debate even emerge
to answer the question
he said to me i have three conditions
the first condition is that i will not
be muted if i'm not mistaken the second
condition was that he's going to ask
five questions the first condition is
that he doesn't want to be called apus
is that correct apus
no i didn't say that you did say that
you said i want to be called by my name
not but being called an apus yeah i said
my three conditions are five questions
that you refer to me only as a party
prophet or your title in the stream and
three that you will not mute me yes
that's the three conditions
you explicitly asked me for a specific
title which i didn't say
that's what you mentioned that that's
what that's okay okay no problem
whatever okay no problem now firstly i
said i have no right i mean i have no
reason to accept your condition look
let's get something right here i've got
nearly tripled the followers you have
let's go look at him you need me
bruv look at myself and yet you
challenged me i didn't challenge you
well you need me
and you challenged me i didn't did i
challenge you to a debate did i
challenge you to a debate
we're gonna come together die challenger
to a debate or did you do children yet
we're gonna come to that i challenge you
to a debate don't you challenge me you
challenged me
no you did you challenged me no no no no
no in the beginning two years ago
you even said to me i initiated the
offer that's what you just said okay did
you not tell me that you would want to
debate me this is two years ago not
recently talk about two years ago did
you not keep challenging me to an online
debate
you first did i don't think i initiated
that i am am i definitely
i might have at some point said yeah
sure yes i want to have this debate i
don't know but it was you who initiated
you on twitter said uh come to speaker's
corner and this and this that was the
first challenge okay as far as whatever
it is as far as i remember you might be
correct yes allah says in the quran
speak the truth even is against yourself
i'll speak the truth if you claim that
if either i challenge you i've been
changing regardless did i not say to you
because i need to do another check this
year yeah did i not say to you come to
london i'll pay for your ticket i'll pay
for your one-star hotel okay and we will
have a debate
yes okay did you say yes what did i say
i said no to that okay good one second
one second one i need to get my notes
out yeah hello hello
yes give me a minute just give me a
second yes yes
why what's going on
are you are you googling
hey first are you googling i can't see
you
i can't see are you googling what would
i be what would i be googling you're the
google master you don't come my bedroom
how can i let me guess how do i win a
muslim in the debate i'm actually live
streaming on my own channel
by the way put this up it shouldn't be
unlisted yeah okay and don't call it oh
really oh really
this was that was the interview you know
like uh
yeah you're having too many interviews
you should be a reporter you should
apply for journalism
all right let's see come on hey first i
could be a click click i can hear click
click
okay come on don't cut your computer
don't get your computer yeah that's what
was face to face i wanna look at you in
the eyes
i am live streaming on my own channel
right now why do you think that's fine
that's fine do you think do you think
it's very interesting that you accuse me
of looking something up people can see
me right on my screen no problem no
problem it's fine it's okay it's a child
man yes yes no problem anyway so okay
where were we i invited you to london
did you say yes or no
uh
no i said no okay good so that's one no
okay
then some time went by you came back
again because your guests
challenge everybody and you get smashed
for everybody but you can't carry on
challenging but consistency is key
anyway so carry on so anyways do you
said to me online debate i said to you
no
face to face did you say yes or no to a
face to face
uh and initially i said no yeah good
okay then after some pressure you said
yes face-to-face then you said audience
audience did you say yes or no to an
audience
uh
if we didn't talk about an audience i
initially said we meet face to face no
audience
good so no audience okay and that didn't
happen after pressure that happened
because i made arrangements with money
to do this yeah yeah you yeah yeah
that's what happened yeah okay yeah i
can leave you we believe okay so when it
comes to when you're gonna laugh a lot
we're having fun yeah
i don't know it's gonna be this one okay
after that i thought it will come to my
backstory no no we are we are we are so
anyways yeah you're gonna that's right
you're gonna have to have your say on it
just to be fair okay now so did you when
i said i'm gonna stream on my channel
did you say yes or no
i said no because modern day debate is
the organizer so they should have
exclusivity in terms of streaming live
and afterwards we can publish it that's
what i said
i've got
four
no's here
oh when someone says no
no no no
it's a no
so now the thing i'm asking is the
following i'm asking for you to come i'm
paying for your ticket and one star
hotel to come you say no
i say face to face you say no i say oh
dear you say no i say can i stream you
say no
you
or the only word you know is no so then
afterwards we agreed that i come to
america i travel all the way 13 hours
to come there yeah to do your
intellectual burial yeah so
therefore when i came i said new york
california or somewhere else one of
these free okay that's the only thing
that i said okay we agreed on i spoke to
james and james was busy we agreed on
california and i was looking for
sacramento i had no idea that u.s is
that strict on uh getting a job okay i
don't want to mention the words they're
going to bloody end up censoring it they
were this strict my team in california
which i have screenshots of said to me
you have to get vaccine and i thought to
myself no i'm sure i can come and show
the ivan uh i don't have the virus they
said you are not getting in when i found
that out i came and i said james i
cannot get in is this true
and which you guys confirm no you can't
so i know you're looking for any excuse
for it not to happen so i said what is
the closest country that you can come
without an excuse mexico that's the only
place i know you're not going to come
anywhere else i said mexico did you say
yes or no to a mexico
i said no okay that's five no's so i'm
going to give it to you now you can if
you want to explain your side i have
five notes please tell me how these are
yes
okay apparently we are doing this
instead of uh doing alidawah's part of
the agreed mubarak so
he's not keeping up any of his
agreements again as usual i'm not
surprised but fine if you want to so
badly go through with questions and
answers let's do this dear alidawah
please answer to me
at the beginning of our debate talks
that we are having that we have had now
who initiated the debate was it you or
me
who initiated debate was it you or me
i can't remember
either you or me
okay it was you nobody and i don't know
yeah we do we do uh you even sent me the
first first message i can i can show
that i i already did show that to my
audience before there's possibility that
you did
no it's is there a chance there's no
chance there's no chance that with the
right there's no chance
in our current talks it was most
definitely you who did this so used you
even next you even said that you said i
initiated it so
you initiated the offer you challenged
me to a debate right what did i say to
you did i
uh not say
i do online debates we can have an
online debate hosted by modern day
debate is that what i said as a response
to your challenge yeah that's what i
said right so you challenged me i said
online right
yeah yeah after some time i said to you
because you said hey you are scared to
face me i said oh you think i'm scared
to face you okay let's let's let's
arrange a debate face to face in texas
right
now or did i not did i or did i not do
that yes off he said no okay you
rejected that and you said it must be
with audience after some time i talked
with modern day debate and said he said
hey we have a debate uh in texas
arranged we can host you there and i
said hey look we have an audience we
have face-to-face that's all the
conditions that you asked for come to
texas and what did you say you said yes
right
i didn't say your agreement you agreed
no no i said i can't make it in january
remember okay five okay you're right
the marriage you agree you agreed to it
first but you said you said i can't come
in january but why couldn't i come
did i interrupt you earlier i'm sorry
i'm sorry
okay yeah you said you said you can't do
january you would like to do may right
so what you then said is i didn't say
maybe
okay fine fine i correct james said we
have a date in may ready and you said
okay may works for me
then you asked me to do it in london i
said no not london i will not come there
you said okay i will come to your
country and we will do it there did you
or did you not say that yes
okay you did say that
and you said new york uh
california or
london i don't know why you i don't know
mentioned london no i actually have the
message here you said california new
york and london apparently london is
also here i don't know but that's what
you said
yes
afterwards
curiously for some reason on december
10th and i have i have the receipts here
you told me specifically
if for some reason i cannot get into the
u.s
we will do the debate somewhere else
correct right correct and what did i say
in response to you did i agree to that
uh remind me i cannot remember
i said i will not accept any other
conditions except the these okay and
mentions to you again that's correct
so
you so you admit that i never agreed to
such a condition i explicitly rejected
that i explicitly said i will only
accept these conditions here in america
because it's you who insists on face to
face not me i can do it online today if
you want to
okay okay i i accepted that that's
correct yep okay december 10th you said
if anything happens we will do it
somewhere else and this will not stop us
you've somehow said that on december
10th then you said i need to talk with
my uh with some people i i will get back
to you whether we can do it in texas or
not or somewhere else or not then you
got back a few days later and said yes
we can do it what did you do in that
meantime why did you not try to find out
whether you can enter america or not
okay can i answer
sure just give me the answer to that yes
so the answer to that is i did not even
think that you cannot get in i didn't
that even got crossed my mind because
i've traveled to turkey which i know you
can't go because of some using some
terror organizations that blow
theirselves up or something like that
that's not true actually that's not true
i actually cannot go to turkey because
uh there is a court order against me
because i insulted islam okay but also
involved in a terrorist organization and
fbi i wasn't i was never i was never
involved in that i didn't come to your
door
i did come to my door because somebody
reported me and they asked me well they
have a right to down report you if
you're a terrorist oh come on danny do
you believe that if you have they asked
them they asked me about
they asked me about a false they asked
me about a false complaint they actually
worked together
i am in contact with the fbi i was part
of it
yeah i'm the muslim that's supposed to
you know we are labeled with that yeah
because that's what you mean it's your
guys who blow things up i don't you know
that's ironic though the thing is you
blame us and you're somebody who was
with us with people planning on blowing
this no no i wasn't i wasn't i wasn't i
was how ironic i was
stop change i wasn't stopped changing
the topic why did you not
why did you not find
did you really
why did you need one day or two days to
make sure if you can or cannot come but
you didn't know that you needed a
vaccine to enter america does that make
sense okay i can't make sense of it no
no you can make sense in this very well
you can't you're someone that doesn't
believe in god believe everything popped
into existence so i don't blame you
doesn't make sense to you the reason is
because i had to find out where we're
doing it new york or california okay i
had to discuss which because we want an
audience this is from your side and our
side as well so new york was good when
how many jobs smashed david wood bury
them days with his funeral was there so
that's why i was like allah prays for
muhammad not to muhammad right
go ahead sure go ahead you got a joke i
didn't get it
allah prays for me i've never had dead
jokes before uh you had it but i have to
give it to you your dead jokes are whoa
you're anyway
i wanted to walk off stage damn that was
that's such an amazing feeling
so that's why basically
i was checking where can we do it new
york or california that's what i was
looking at to tell james james new york
is better because he said to me ali can
you look at venues i'm busy
i didn't even look at vaccines or um
visa or anything like that applying i
was just looking at
can where can we do new york california
where because james was saying los
angeles oh new york is um are you saying
like they're liberal they're going to
tell us where master i want you guys to
see your facial expressions ask him
that's what he said so does that make
sense hope that's a question
that's a question i don't know why you
always have to give me a novel for to
some simple question but yeah sure uh
have you never
have you never heard of you know travel
bans and vaccine requirements and all
that since the beginning of it i mean
wasn't it very clear to you
i have even your own country demands
that i cannot come to the uk if i don't
have a vaccine no is it
look that's news to me so you're telling
me that you cannot come into the uk
without a vaccine yes
that's news to me i'll tell you saying i
went to turkey i'll be honest with you i
went to turkey and when i went to turkey
they said you have to prove that you
have no covet when you enter the country
and i said well that's calm i wasn't
even thinking of going turkey so when i
went in i thought it's not that deep as
people make it out to be like you can't
go get a job etc and especially after
what happened to some people that i know
even mohammed hijab when he developed
certain blood clots i don't want to get
into this because they're going to
censor it yeah when he got that
then to me i was like i firstly i had it
i had covet and i got over it it wasn't
that deep so i was thinking why do i
need that anyways so when that happened
to hijab i said personally look people
should take i'm not telling no one to
take it take it i
prefer not to simply oh you are against
vaccinations in general right now
i wouldn't i wouldn't say that i would
say personally each individual you have
to because at the end of the day if if
for example the the the offer of the
people like we live at time where people
if it's needed and it's going to protect
if they believe it's going to protect
that's calm you should obey the law of
the land it's as simple as that as
muslims our contracts are very very
important so that's why i'm not telling
anyone not to take i'm saying personally
me me i prefer not okay but you are
personally against the vaccines right no
i don't want to take it how you i'm
telling you i don't want to take you
just keep telling me personally
personally
i'm telling you i don't want to yeah
that's that's what i'm saying personally
that's why you're saying that i believe
no one should take it i never said that
i never said that okay sorry okay
aren't these your words uh
um
wait last i remember my friend mohammed
hijab whom i'm sure you remember well
took the jab and was nearly dying due to
blood clots and that wasn't my reason
i've been staying away from it since i
stay away from many vaccines so i
haven't taken and don't want to take it
aren't those your words so you are
personally what's that what does that
mean
people shouldn't take it i don't i never
said people shouldn't take it okay i yes
i don't want you my immune system okay
have something
honey
some black seed oil you're good to go
okay fine that's that's very nice uh
can i ask you a very personal question
for just a minute do you also uh what
what about kids like when you have kids
do you also think my kids shouldn't have
vaccine
i'm just curious right now but to be
honest as as their parent who loves them
i will do what's best for them
okay fine
including uh okay we'll get to that
we'll get to that we'll get to that i'm
gonna get to that we're getting into a
lot of places today no no after all of
that let me ask you a question
i say
i say i say we have an online debate you
say no it has to be face to face it has
to be face to face
has to be face to face and since you
insist on that you make the offer and
say okay i will come to america you say
it will happen i will come to america
and all that and after everything is
arranged and even publicly announced you
suddenly say oh i can't come to america
because of vaccine now is that my fault
or your fault to be honest it's very
clear firstly i wouldn't say in that
very instance it's anyone's fault if i
say it's your fault that'll be unfair so
i'm not going to say it's your fault
neither i'll say it's my fault so i have
to be just in this matter what i would
say is though for me to invite you and
you're rejecting it yeah for me to say
face to face and you reject it for me to
say audience and you reject it live
streaming rejected we all know that
another thing uh you rejected mexico
thing but you again you said that you
said stipulated that before you're not
traveling in anywhere else i'm assuming
because i'm assuming that you have a
criminal record of the robbery and that
terrorist charge that you're scared if
you leave america they won't let you
back in maybe i'm i'm assuming this i'm
not saying it's a fact it might be that
you're scared to leave the country
because to me
i have charges of terrorism which is how
i entered america and even became a
citizen of america no no but that's the
thing i'm saying for example you know
very well that you was involved with a
group that blow themselves up and you're
the same person i wasn't that's a lie
you're taking antidepressants um and
that you said using a traffic light and
you was concerned with the traffic you
said if the traffic light didn't turn
green you felt like running people over
so i think yeah
it was it was it was a side effect of
agitation which is a response that is
very is very common to antidepressants
do you not do you not know what
anti-depressants are have you never
known people who take antidepressants or
who have sciences
i i have but i've never seen that kind
of um
it's it's quite it's quite normal it's
quite normal you can have psychological
reactions and side effects
i have never seen that you would want to
run over innocent people
yeah i i also i also didn't say i wanted
to do that i said that's how i felt
that's impulsive thinking i know i know
you don't i know you don't understand
psychology but people have intrusive
thoughts as a result of mental problems
that doesn't mean you want to run people
over and kill people okay but it goes
back to these conditions that you make
when i asked you about the whole incest
thing with your own adult child yep see
yeah how did we even get here i'm asking
you a very simple question was it your
fault or my fault now what is that
correlation because you're saying all
the time i would have but is that it's
the same thing you said the same thing
with insisting i yes i believe that if
there is no harm there is no problem
with an individual i was asking
specifically you to have intimacy with
their own adulthood i didn't say
anything about myself i was wrong yes
you did
i didn't say anything about myself
i said i said if there if there was i
said if there was no harm the wording
here is very clear this is a
hypothetical
which is not possible if there was no
harm
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what the harm is the
hypothetical what's the harm it doesn't
matter what the harm is that's that's
not how this works
no that's not how it works you don't
believe it i don't believe in good and
bad okay
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
you're making it you're making an
allegation you're making an allegation
which
i say it is harmful
it is not possible for there not to be
harm if it was not harmful there
wouldn't be anything wrong with it but
since it is harmful it is wrong that's
what i said okay so that does not mean i
would personally do it or find it okay
to do okay did you not go to the podcast
army or interview and he said to you
what is wrong with incest yes you said
uh no no no this is harm he did this no
it's it's like what's at home what's the
harm what's up and then he's like
objectively is any harm he's like um
actually no there is no harm no no it
wasn't that wasn't about incest in
general it was about uh
two consenting individuals who cannot
procreate if there is any harm in that
is there harm in that can you can you uh
demonstrate harm in that no you can't i
can't demonstrate time to that that
doesn't have anything to do with with
justifying or glorifying incest that was
a completely normal philosophical
discussion okay hey apus did you not say
that if there's two consenting adults
you and let's say your grown-up adult
child okay i'm only buying i wasn't
mentioning this because that's your
world view i don't know
as long as there's no harm now if i see
the following tell me what would you
think if i said
i would like to kill
i would like to
execute babies because there's harm i'm
not gonna do it but i want you because
there's harm oh i'm not going to do it
that doesn't make any sense that doesn't
make sense that doesn't make any sense
and it's also a false equivalence
because i never said i would do it
i spoke with a hypothetical and said
there is harm in it
i'm saying if i say if there is no harm
to the baby
i would do i would
equivalence i never said i would do
anything like that you gave me an
example and i evaluated that as a third
person the condition is the time factor
the condition is the harm factor you
said if there is no harm i'm asking you
what is the harm
i don't i don't care i don't care what
the harm is i am telling you you are
misrepresenting the position i never
said i would do anything i said i said
if two individuals were to do that and
there was no harm there would be nothing
wrong with it but that is not reality i
clearly and explicitly said to you but
that is not reality which means there is
harm in that that's what i tell you and
i never spoke to america incest doesn't
happen are you telling me a grown man
okay a grown man
his child okay
okay a grown man yeah uh a let's call
him a and his um a son grown adult who's
18 years old they want to use protection
and have intimacy is there anything
wrong with that
i think
uh
probably it is yes okay what's wrong
with that
well first off it is uh
wait wait you see you said the child is
what is an adult consenting adult
i think it is detrimental to society i
would say it is like i was i would say
it is terrible it is stamina
because because
it normalizes a harmful concept even if
the case in and of itself does not cause
any direct harm does not cause anything
talking about the harm factor you're
talking about to prove it
i'm telling you that it doesn't cause
any i'm telling you it doesn't cause any
direct harm what do you want me to prove
thank you so it doesn't cause any direct
harm no i'm telling you i'm telling you
since uh although the case in and of
itself does not cause any direct harm it
normalizes a specific practice which is
extremely
society which is why it is detestable
and undesirable so how the same thing
the same thing with cannibalism for
example i'm sorry this would be very
strong no no no no no no no no no no
this will be very shocking to you to
hear i know but uh if i said hey i want
to cut off my arm and i want you to eat
this you're allowed to eat it i would
still say hey that's a detestable
horrible practice because what you're
doing is you're normalizing why are you
consenting
i would still say it's a detestable or
why is it
proven what's the harm principle prove
it what do you mean because because
because you're because you're
normalizing a practice if you let me
speak
if you normalize because you're
normalizing a practice that has
otherwise if it is normalized very
detrimental very harmful consequences if
you normalize a a harmless form of
incest for example it is a normalization
of incest in general or moving toward a
normalization of incest which in most
cases is harmful and undesirable
similarly a case of cannibalism which
may be
with consent if you engage in it and say
well there is no harm in this so we can
do it normalizes something that is
extremely detestable extremely harmful
because people could end up eating each
other or hunting for it if they know
that it is legal to eat human flesh same
thing very simple they say consensus so
that means you have a issue with
homosexuality two consenting
because if a lot of people a lot of men
indulge in their homes i don't know i
don't know why we're still talking about
this because
i'm still supposed to ask you about
uh you believe it would have a greater
consequences on society because if all
of them did there would not be
procreation therefore you are against
homosexuality so no that's that's not
our that's not how homosexuality works
people do not engage in homosexuality
that's not how they find atm people do
not
define
people people do not become homosexual
or start engaging in all sexual
interactions because some people do it
people have sexual preferences and
desires that's not how it works
if you are secretly if you are secretly
gay i don't it's
this is my point that is their sexual
preference incest a a grown adult man
and his grand adult child who use
protection there is no harm there is no
harm that's not a sexual preference
there is no harm and you cannot answer
you know why because you know let me
tell you what i just did let me tell you
something let me answer one of my family
members one of my family members sent me
a video and they were like yeah see this
guy and i was like do you know this
guy's pro incest i swear to god his
mouth went like this
no he's not i said yeah i said what's
this video he never sent me a video ever
again in his life well you're you're
also pro-terrorism no exactly yeah okay
you're pro-terrorism
okay
wait you heard me okay what about
necrophilia my point is just because i
say something about you and show people
certain footage that doesn't mean it's
true you're talking about
if there's a dead corpse uh let's
suppose you pass away and somebody comes
and wants to rape your dead body is that
right or wrong is that is that just just
just come back to these stop deflecting
and going into a completely different
territory
listen
we are still we're still at talking
about a debate you are already already
not keeping up your agreement to answer
my five questions so please stop
deflecting come back to the debate
that's right that's what we are okay you
you deflect it from the debate and the
vaccine to incest to mental health now
now to now to having sex with dead
people what the hell is wrong with you
no no no no come back to the truth
what's wrong with you
come back to the topic come back to the
topic come on okay
what the hell is wrong with you i don't
i don't care i know you are you might
have uh homosexual tendencies you might
be interested in me you have been
frantically tweeting about me i don't
care about any of that okay let's get
back to the vaccine issue let's get back
to the debate you cannot care you know
why you're ashamed and you are somebody
who has a common question that's a
morality you somebody who you
have cannot bring
why incest is wrong why necrophilia is
wrong you cannot bring evidence you and
you want to bring that's morality rather
my family who sent me that he wanted to
vomit when i should hurt you right now
nothing wrong with hurting i'm hurting
you what happened
okay
you agreed to answer my five questions
you are not keeping up that agreement
obviously you are breaking your
agreement right no i didn't i heard you
i never stuck to it you know what let me
show you let me show you evidence no
you're explicit
is this you is this you i can share my
screen it's okay well one second
i can i can share my screen
to it screen reader
watch this yeah okay sure uh
okay one second
oh i've got a screenshot here guys and
i'm going to show you guys as well
okay
okay so there you go so he goes to me
yeah you have to say free yes to all
three of them and that's how this goes
and then we can meet tomorrow at 8pm
then i said now i don't agree to none of
them
after you i said i agree to the five
questions and you not being muted and
then you said no you have to agree to
the third one that we don't call you
apus yeah because you're a little apus
yeah and then i said you know what i
don't agree to none of them now
i revoked it yeah been revoked and the
evidence is there okay so um let's go to
another issue yeah which is uh
oh yeah so okay one-sidedly you
apparently said in the middle of it no i
don't agree to one of them okay is this
this concept so you so you did agree to
two conditions and then you just backed
out of it right you know what contingent
means now i don't i don't care about you
i don't care about you you know what
contingent means no i'm asking i don't
care about your dumb questions do you
want to do you want to get back to our
actual agreement or not no he went to
agreement
so you challenged me to a debate
agreed to have the debate in america
you're done you're finished you're
finished boy you're finished now
so you so you agreed to
to you you offered a debate in america
and then you backed out of it due to
your own mistake
and you say that is not that is nobody's
fault it is your fault isn't it why do
you challenge me to a debate and then
you don't go through with it why do you
not want to have a debate
why is it my fault that you want to do
it in person even your own audience look
everybody muslim listeners i said to him
make a poll to your own followers and
ask them if an online debate should
should take place or not he didn't want
to do it because he knows that even his
own audience and i have screenshots tons
of them will say do it do it please
you are embarrassing us i mean i have
messages here they say i am you are
embarrassing us muslims they want this
to happen but you are backing out of it
making dumb excuses offering a
face-to-face challenge in america then
backing out of it because you apparently
didn't know that you need a vaccine this
is all your fault why will you not
simply agree to an online debate you
have wasted over an hour here with me no
other but you can't but you cannot
but you cannot agree to a debate what is
this about muhammad is the same thing he
said i will not do an online debate then
he sat down with me for two hours what
is what is wrong with you people yeah
what's wrong with an online debate
you're too you're too late for me why
would you not do an online debate yeah
you know like after if you've spoken
okay all right thank you yeah why would
you not do an online debate answer the
questions
i try my best not to cut you because i
don't want to make excuses they cut me
they muted me i'm not like you're
fantastic i've been doing that the
entire time
let's go through your reputation yeah
have i ever i've have i've had
face-to-face debates have you ever had a
face-to-face debate in your life uh no i
haven't okay let's add another note to
that bloody this
did you ever have moderated debates no
no i haven't drive moderation
but no no you didn't not in a building
i had never had moderation
like not organized eventually no i have
but not in that context when when did
you have a moderate debate who was it
like no no i did but not in a in a
closed place that's okay give me an
example give me an example let's for
example speakers corner somebody speak i
speak they speak i speak but not in the
way like you said
do you think do you think that's what a
moderated debate is no no somebody
moderating it but not in a building
that's what i'm saying yeah okay that
makes sense that makes no sense now let
me ask you something have i ever been
defeated in a debate the way you have
and unlisted the video
i don't know what you're talking about i
had never i never understood videos
in which he said it wasn't a it wasn't a
debate he said it was he himself said it
was a discussion i later unlisted it
well for several different reasons
number one daniel kikichu said we would
have a debate in the future because that
was not a debate as he explicitly says
on the stream later he turned away from
that yeah uh secondly because he
personally insulted me and uh sent his
old army against me i said hey if you
want to conduct yourself like that i'm
not up for that that's it and the third
reason was as such
that we would revisit a debate and he
did not do it because he wanted to stick
to that and i said hey i will not give
you free publicity i unlist this for now
later i listed it again that's it and
what did what exactly did he prove
during that debate during that
discussion
what what do you think what do you think
he did in that
in the discussion if you call it a
debate if you call it a debate okay what
do you think he did what was his great
point against before he made you accept
the the point of slavery
i already i accepted that prior to him i
accepted that prior to him i already
said before him before the conversation
with him look we got smashed here now
tell me do i have any debate
explain explain it to me explain this no
since you made claims about how i got
destroyed explain it to me what was the
point that that destroyed listen to me
there was none explain it to me i'm
excited i don't care what i don't care
who that was explain to me what was the
point you got annihilated okay
my debate any facebook
i had that i had to unleash the video
i didn't have a debate where i unlisted
the video
i don't follow your videos the way you
follow mine i'm not a fan of him you're
a fan of questions
lauren answer my questions
answer my question none of them
requested this video i had to upload it
rob and somebody has ever been defeated
by a 17 year old boy i don't know i'm
not a fan of you you're a fan of mine i
don't follow your stuff
answer my question since you say i have
been destroyed which i don't care about
please tell me the points tell me the
arguments on which i have been destroyed
come on you know what do you want to
debate atheism in islam tell me the
arguments
in islam tell me the arguments
in islam tell me the arguments which
destroyed my position islam i will
debate now the contingency argument
right now let's go
no let's go is this contingent you know
what it means
yes it is it's continuous okay
relatively according to the argument yes
it is dependent yes sure can it be any
other way
it could be yes okay good okay so it's
independent it could be any other way
it's contingent okay okay can we let's
do this okay one second do you accept
that there is existence
yes thank you okay there's three kinds
of existence yeah okay there is uh
impossible existence there is possible
existence and there's necessary
existence impossible a very dumb way of
putting that's true for one second it's
a triangle circle yeah you're gonna need
to with that water i know you're getting
nervous
i know you're getting nervous you're
gonna you're gonna get just stop just
just go with the point i'm gonna be your
worst nightmare you're gonna have
nightmares about me yeah sure sure go
ahead yeah go ahead come on okay a
triangle circle is an impossible
existence it cannot exist so we have two
things left
um possible existence and necessary
existence yeah that's correct yeah okay
now
do you know what contingent is you know
the criteria for contingency what what
what contingent thing which we just we
just went through that why do you okay
one more time make your arguments make
your arguments don't know what to do
what is it let's go again
that's not how you make an argument you
are supposed to make your argument
you know i'm asking you do you know what
contingent what's the christmas you're
supposed to make your argument not ask
me questions yeah i don't know just make
your goddamn argument yeah i don't know
i just told you the answer dude no no no
i'm gonna teach you i just gave you the
answer i'm your teacher i just gave you
the answer just make your argument
i have to ask you i'm teaching a lesson
you have to know i need to see if you're
casual
okay you are so goddamn childish make
your point stop asking questions okay it
cannot be any other way okay it requires
something else for its own existence
okay can you have
an infinite regress of dependent things
uh it's not something we can know you
could say you could argue that uh it is
something that doesn't exist you could
argue that it does exist people are
actually split on that even the guy
himself who talked to me is split on the
definition of infinite and of on on
actual infinites and not actually
infinites do you know what that means
you probably don't know what that
actually infinite is in the real world
there is potential infinite but actual
infinite doesn't exist in the real world
if i had fun
do you think do you think the 17 year
old debater from a few days ago i agrees
with you listen listen i don't know do
you think he agrees with me that's not
an issue i'm saying to you
he says he says it can't exist i'm
giving an analogy he says it's kind of
stupid i can hear you click i know
you're going google i'm not quick
okay so i'm saying to you that you can
you can you have uh infinite in the real
world no if i had if there was infinite
amount of apuses may allah protect us
and i slapped two and they and it died
okay how many apres are there
keep making your arguments come on no
i'm asking questions questions make your
argument argument
infinite doesn't exist in the real world
so therefore i'm telling you have you
ever made an actual argument
asking questions okay can there be an
infinite um um are you dumb you are
asking me a question again
make your argument stop asking me
questions
make your argument stop asking questions
amount of dependent things could be i
don't know no dependent
no dependent no sorry dependent no
that's
i just said no i misspoke i misspoke i
said no okay dependent therefore
therefore
you require a necessary being for order
in all those dependent things to fall
back on now what's the condition for
unnecessary being do you know
go ahead you don't know i don't know
just go ahead and make your argument
say ali i don't know go ahead make your
argument
please tell me teacher please tell me
now let me tell you if you're a bad
student yeah you guys never talk to a
more annoying person make your goddamn
arguments come on get to the point
fail you failed you're finished
a necessary being is a being that is
independent self-sufficient cannot be
composed by parts or cannot be any other
way according to which principle
according to what standard is that is
that according to what standard is that
the definition of unnecessary the
logical uh principles
what
a logical principle under what standard
uh by what definition is that the
definition of an association being
explained
okay
please
why is that the definition of a
necessary being contingent things is
what dependent
uh requires something else for its own
existence it's composed by past and can
be any other way so which follows the
unnecessary being has to be the opposite
because the necessary being is opposite
of the dependent thing so now you tell
me can we have a c without a seabed
it could be the answer
wow okay we need to do abc here no you
can't do you think i don't know the
answer i'm telling you i have been
telling you for 10 minutes now to make
your art
your brain how could you have c just
make your argument man stop talking just
make you argue you're not you're not
even engaging you know why because you
know you got slapped up
but you look like you're gonna cry okay
are you gonna cry are you done with the
arguments therefore are you done with
the arguments
are you done with the argument you have
yes i'm done with argument can you
rebuke it okay okay of course i can
create for you based on based on what uh
exactly is a god and necessary being
explain it to me
again king cream in here don't be
jealous
based on what exactly is got the
necessary being mashallah sorry
based on what is god the necessary being
click click
click once again i said to you we have
dependent things
we require something that's based on
what is god they're necessarily being
answered no no no no no no i never i
know what once again i didn't go to god
yet i'm trying to move you from atheism
to deism i haven't even gone to that yet
i didn't say that did i say anything
about god i just did anything about god
yeah okay so you keep clicking your
teacher it's not going to help you yeah
okay you're finished well you're
finished okay one life
when you're finished
okay
what is the necessary being the
necessary being could be anything what
is the necessary
argument good so do you accept that
there's a necessary being
depends on what you would define but
what you mean by necessary being okay
it could be that existence itself is
disturbing it could be that energy
dependent it's self-sufficient it's not
complicated okay
i'm giving you a response to
your stupid question necessarily
a necessary being could be anything it
could be energy it could be uh
prior prior to the big bang a perfect
balance of energy by the way you
probably don't even know what's bigger
the perfect balance of energy it could
be
it could be a multiverse it could be a
multiverse which exists it could be a
hierarchy of deities that
is combined by a problem a circle that
forms a necessary being what is a
necessary being that you need to define
that in order to explain to me that a
necessary being proves the existence of
god you need to first answer to me why
you think a necessary being must exist
in all worlds and why you think that
fits the criteria of a god that you
believe in but of course you can't do
that because you don't even know what
you're talking about because you can't
even tell me why a necessary being has
this definition you don't even know the
name of the argument which you're
proposing are you finished
yes because you are finished in a minute
listen
universe multiverse superverse super
mario verse energy energy energy
whatever you want to call it they all
are infinitely rely on the
necessary boss yes now once again let me
look around listen to me okay listen to
you listen to me yeah okay
just for just to be charitable i'm
having this to show how ignorant you are
i don't even try to travel to you
where's
it anyway
[Laughter]
uh as far as we know not does he have a
will
as far as we know not no
intelligence
as far as we know we're not no
it was your finish man my gosh this was
okay okay okay how does energy okay give
rise to beings like us who have
consciousness who have a will and who
have intelligence sorry i don't know and
that's what allah says in the quran
ask them
you know what they will say okay i don't
know
enough for me to believe well right
you're such a giant you know what an
atheist is it's like coming outside my
door and saying get out get out get out
and i'm okay are you done are you are
you done i don't know are you done
are you done so
where in your argument for a necessary
being
where in your argument is the
requirement that this is a conscious
people don't raise your voice at me
where in your argument is the
requirement that this is actually trust
me everybody sees what a dumb child of
course engage with you engage with your
argument i'm happy you are giving me
you're giving me the argument are you
going to let me speak okay
you're making an argument from
contingency and then you appeal to god
with arguments that are completely
outside the argument in order to say
that this is the necessary being so you
are using
completely different arguments to make
your point where exactly in your initial
argument was it a requirement for a
necessary being to be conscious to have
a person to be a a thing that moves to
have an intellect where exactly was that
and how exactly can you prove
that that is necessary in order to bring
life into existence do you have research
papers for that go ahead prove it to me
come on
i know you are a stupid child go ahead
engage with the argument instead of
talking nonsense come on
okay go ahead
brother go ahead
come on
okay
okay okay go ahead so the question you
asked was did you make notes did i no no
i don't know it's for you
for you the only one answer the question
the f the f i want to give you that's
the only know i have answer the question
come on answer the question yeah okay um
what was the question ask again
secondly secondly can you prove or can
you present proper evidence that a
person or a conscious being is required
for life or for consciousness to come
into existence okay good firstly go
ahead look look i firstly never said
that that is a personal being i'm
telling you i haven't even moved there
yet do you accept a necessary being if
you say yes from there then i can prove
to you why that is a personal god who
has consciousness and uh has a will and
erada i haven't even gone there yet i'm
saying do you accept a necessary being
exists
i just talked to you about how it could
be energy and you asked me questions
about energy
about the about qualities of energy no
no so you know why that answers my
question let me tell you why you gave
the issue of energy yeah okay
okay i have to i have to mute you for a
second you have no idea what you're
talking about you have no idea what
you're talking about me don't worry i've
got it don't worry about that okay okay
you have no idea what you're talking
about i just i just brought up energy
you as a response said energy doesn't
have a purse a personality what did you
say to me and then you say i never said
it
you
energy of consciousness no does he ever
will no uh does it have intelligence no
therefore it cannot give rise to
something like us who has intelligence
who is conscious and is a will okay
because if it doesn't let me finish if
it doesn't have that innate properties
that you let me finish every time you
know what you're doing but i've been
finished let me finish my point i'll
listen to you let me finish my point
okay don't get angry it's not my fault
ignoramus don't blame me don't get angry
at me yeah
so i'm saying this if you're telling me
energy is a possibility energy has no
consciousness he has no will and he has
no intelligence so therefore when i'm
talking about a necessary being it
requires for him to have there has to be
he has to be the only knowing he has to
have some kind of an existence he has to
exist but not the way we exist okay and
he has to have iran and will to give
rise to us
okay so you just said you just said that
you never made such a condition
you just said that you never have such
never made such a condition
which is why i brought up energy as a
possible necessary existence upon which
you said it can't be energy because
energy doesn't have a consciousness
doesn't have intellect and doesn't have
a will
so it is part of your argument and you
used it in order to refute me that
energy cannot be the necessary being
because it doesn't have a personality it
doesn't have a will it doesn't have a
consciousness
and then you appeal to god because god
has a consciousness has a personality as
a being and your reasoning for that is
that
something without a personality without
consciousness cannot bring consciousness
into existence you are a complete idiot
you are a complete idiot where was that
requirement in your argument for a
necessary peak you are such a [ __ ]
thank you thank you okay perfect
presentation everybody knows he said you
are so brilliant thank you so enjoyable
that's right
hypothesized with it one second no no
you you first tried to escape it yeah
you know that hypothetically
being then no i hypothesized that's all
that's how philosophy works even your
friends will tell you this laptop you
can't stop i'm hypothesizing with the
possibilities that we talked about let
me talk yeah let me talk okay i'll
listen to you okay people are watching
okay alhamdulillah people are watching
yeah now we talked about necessary being
i gave you the conditions for necessary
being and then you said to me how is he
personal how does he mean he has
consciousness i and then you mentioned
energy
i said to you
if you believe energy that has no
consciousness
no will no intelligence that can give
rise to us so something that doesn't
have the innate properties that we have
yeah and and that can give rise to us
but a personal being a necessary being
who is independent self-sufficient not
composed of parts cannot be any other
way him having consciousness and a will
and a um intelligence knowledge
impossible you are a [ __ ] you were the
stupidest guy i've made in my life okay
do you have psychological issues
did you define
early earlier you're defined in your
channel and you're getting destroyed
i'm having mercy on you are you
how could you
earlier when you defined a necessary
being did you define this necessary
being as a being that must have a
consciousness an intel an intellect no i
didn't you did not
okay okay number one number one that is
bad but but then you try to refuse
but then you try to refute uh the energy
point by saying it can't it can't be
energy because it doesn't have a will
okay fine although that is completely
stupid it has nothing to do with the
argument i accept that as a proposition
and then ask you can you show me can you
demonstrate to me that a will a person a
personality is required in order to
bring beings or conscious beings into
existence can you demonstrate that to me
then you say no no no no let's get back
to the argument i'm asking you a simple
question can you demonstrate that to me
can you demonstrate to me that you must
have a conscious personal being in order
to bring life into existence in order
for life to exist how can you do that
based on what evidence you've asked me
listen to me carefully because genuinely
bro you're i didn't want to call you
back stop with the insults just just
give me the answer apus i am i am i'm
just saying you're looking stupid listen
to what i'm saying carefully you said we
see it right
right here everyone is laughing at you
listen you said why can't that not be
energy okay
i want to give you an example is there
an empty glass couple
yeah yeah i'm asking a simple question
okay you said to me it can be energy
okay
if it does not if this does not have the
properties
the properties to make a strawberry
milkshake yeah
to say to say if it doesn't have those
elements it cannot give rise to it
it doesn't have it innately you are
telling me do you know what energy is no
let me finish
how do you think the big bang is
explained how do you think the existence
of the first thing is explained
listen to me listen listen
what do you think do you think the big
bang comes out of nothing listen to me
i'm saying to you you said to me it can
be energy look even though
yeah you guys had a little debate even
he refuted you listen to me carefully
you said it can be energy okay i said to
you does energy have consciousness
you said no does it have a will you said
no does he have intelligence you said no
first of all i said as far as we as far
as we know you know i know you're
cutting because you're hurt let me
finish yeah energy that doesn't have
these properties uh characteristics we
have gave rise to us meaning it doesn't
have innately but spontaneously we have
consciousness and intelligence
once again it develops here but you are
the same guy that says a necessary being
cannot be
um have existence consciousness have a
will and be happy
when did i say that you did because
you're saying how does that uh how did
it give rise to us how does that make
sense that's what you see
are you dumb is it
because i'm asking because i'm asking
you how do you know this is god that
that means i say it cannot be my
conscious being are you completely
stupid when did i say that are you dumb
man painting painting
when did i ever say that can you can you
show me where i said that can you tell
me how you came to that conclusion okay
guys uh if you want me you just made it
you just made a claim how did i come to
that
from the conclusion let me demonstrate
to you yeah yeah i'm speaking how do you
come to the congo let me finish let me
finish when did i say when did i say it
can't be a personal being
okay that's what you said no i didn't
okay clarify
i asked you
how you can demonstrate that it is your
god that's all i said i i haven't even
caught when did i say to you that is
allah when did i even mention good to
you i said to you is there a necessary
being you said to me it can be energy it
can be this and they are all negate what
because i said it cannot be any other
way it cannot be composed of parts
energy has been crossed apart multiverse
is composed of parts it's dependent it's
not independent yeah and then you and
then you brought forth to me a
requirement that it must be personal
which is a requirement that you made up
of this
i listen to you listen to me i'm
teaching you here just be humble and say
ali i don't know the contingency
argument i'm learning
i have actually read books about this
and taken classes did you go to
university
did you go did you go to university bob
jake you messaged jake and said did you
did you take your university class in
psychology
you know i'm sorry i didn't engage with
the argument there now i'm saying to you
the following
let me speak let me make my case stop do
something interrupting me yeah i have
actually read books about about this
stuff okay you know yeah i'm getting
smashed i'm getting
should i share my screen no problem no
that's fine that's fine let me ask you a
simple question okay
you said to me i never mentioned god i
never mentioned allah i didn't mention
none of that i'm saying necessary being
when did i ever mention allah when there
ever mentioned god i never i said yeah
the point is i said if even
and i said no
because it can be any other way it's
composed of parts it's dependent it
requires something else for its own
existence so is that part of the
argument for a necessary being it's not
no you're not understanding i'm telling
you
i'm understanding very clearly is that
part is that part of the argument
foreign
sure let me ask you a simple question
since you are so confident
can i speak this can i speak now can i
speak you come here i'm speaking excuse
me excuse me you cut me out let me let
me i let you speak for the most of the
time can i speak i didn't even finish my
points just okay go ahead go ahead
finish finish come on i never mentioned
allah or god i mentioned necessary being
i said do we accept except as necessary
being and then i said to you
the conditions for that you said to me
energy multiverse and i said no it
cannot be and i gave you my examples
then you came and said how is that allah
how was that god i didn't even mention
it now you if you accept necessary being
then say to me ali okay necessary
how do you how can you prove that is
allah then i will say okay
are you done oh yes that's all you
apparently you're stupid enough to
remember that i very clearly said
assuming that it is a necessary being
how would you conclude that this is
allah
so i i i actually did exactly what you
now tell me i should have done
and then you come back with such a
response i mean you are such a [ __ ]
it's unbelievable but since we are since
you are so confident about this and
since people are uh seeing what an idiot
you are uh concerning theological
discussions i mean go watch some debates
do some things please
but but since you are so confident let
me ask you a few questions
since you want to be an educator and a
teacher on these complex topics uh where
you don't even understand the terms that
you're talking about uh first question
and second question
first question is how many books have
you read about arguments for theism or
atheism second question
uh did you take any university class
which includes philosophy
go ahead
it's got nothing to do with the
discussion please go please go ahead and
answer the question
you asked a lot of things
you asked a lot of things that have
nothing to do with our discussion i'm
just asking something with it because
you can't even answer you know what's
bad okay how many books have you read
i just answered my question come on okay
okay okay no problem i've read arguments
no books and uh i went to no university
argument's sake okay how many have you
done okay how many of you that's not
that's not for arguments it's the
reality it's the reality
it's the reality okay okay reality how
many have you done
i have read quite
many books on theology and philosophy i
have taken certain uh online
certificates online courses in official
courses and i also took uh
undergraduate
courses in two fields of philosophy okay
and you want
without having done anything let me get
this right i'm somebody argumentative
i've read no books i have no university
degrees
i'm going to give it to apus he's got
he's made he's read many books he's
have you ever heard of something like
this you're reading books i have an
argument
buy something like this
buy something like this and then try to
run away from me so now tell me will you
accept the necessary being now after you
got refuted
we are already done with this topic you
have demonstrated what a complete idiot
we're done with this people are laughing
at your eagles
no we haven't finished
you know what you know what you should
do
you should take this section you should
take this section and publish it and say
and say ignorant atheist destroyed by
knowledgeable muslim published
perception please it would be amazing
look it's going to be great
people are going to be correct no
problem i've got no no no worry with
that it's going to be great
publish it say say ex-muslim atheist
destroyed on god
educated by muslim okay somebody who's
read books and apparently has teachers
yeah he is running away from a debate
again do you accept the necessary
meaning
we already talked about that we already
talked about it we're done with that
let's go let's come to let's come to my
where does the sun go where does the sun
go at night
where does the sun go at night nearly
two hours
muhammad says in the sun goes somewhere
at night where does it go you're
finished bob you are finished i cannot
believe you've left the debate
i've read so many books and i have
teacher's degrees ali you have none and
i'm running away from debate you coward
you're right you know what
sit down with muhammad
sit down with muhammad job and review
this conversation and let him
you're running away clap an argument
with heaven you carried you showing me
books of atheism and you're running away
okay
are you done are you done with your
comments
are you done with your hands we already
talked about that i already gave you the
answer
you ran away positively okay possibly
that's what i said okay we're done with
this we're done with this
wait okay
we're done with this we are done with
this we are done with this we are not
having a debate
we are not having a debate
we are not having a debate no i said to
you i would debate you on this topic
we're not having a debate
everyone you're not having a debate
people are messaging me they're watching
they're laughing
oh really
yeah i believe you totally
so therefore you accept that there's a
necessary being okay good now that means
that's the criteria for us that there is
a creator why because if you accept a
necessary being you need to acknowledge
that he has to have a will possible
i said possible possible don't try those
words but you're finished the 80s
community are going to divorce you
you're finished they're going to divorce
you they're laughing at you right now
come on okay so if you have something
necessary i don't know we are done with
this nobody is interested in this
conversation come on the necessary being
has to have intelligence right yes or no
no no why not
because it's not part of our definition
of unnecessary being very simple
excuse me
it's not part of the definition of
unnecessary being so we're making it
we're making it personal now okay
depending on depending on what is there
intelligent is there knowledge in the
universe
uh sure is yeah okay
how does a necessary being give rise to
the dependent things contingent things
but has no knowledge how is something
that we uh philosophize and research and
learn and further find out how does it
come into existence according to you do
you have research papers on this what an
answer oh my god you have research
papers on this can you give me some
evidence
you might as well say i like banana
orange and milkshake
is that you don't know what a research
paper is right answer is that i'm asking
you it's a scientific answer actually
very simple
to be honest
i'm asking you yet how does this
what is a research paper i have never
heard of such a thing there is knowledge
is a research paper a banana can you
there's knowledge in the universe it's
intelligence yeah how does the necessity
of being not have none i don't know i
don't know how does it look how does it
again again i don't know
in the quran i don't know
i
how does that show it to me show it to
me how does it okay how does it what
does it come into existence and show it
to me give me research come on let me
show it to me what do you mean
can you see yourself
give me research give me evidence can
you see your consciousness
dude answer my question show it to me
how do you prove your argument
consciousness come on i believe you have
no brain
i can actually show you my consciousness
in terms of hooking things to my brain
showing you activity brain activity when
i'm thinking what i'm dreaming excuse me
yes yes when when two people dream about
similar things they actually have brain
activity that is very similar to each
other
have you have you studied
neuroscientific uh research that's brain
activity
what is brain activity dude where do you
think consciousness works excuse me
excuse me consciousness is something
where is your mind it's in your brain
excuse me your empiricist yeah okay i'm
telling you can you touch consciousness
i cannot touch it no can you see it
i cannot see it no but i can experience
it and i can track it and visually
represent it
no that's not how it works it's idiotic
you cannot taste any other things can
you taste it
make your case
make your case can you taste it make
your case
make your goddamn case you are an idiot
come on make a case but i can smell your
bs can you hear it no therefore it
doesn't exist
yes it is
there you go yes it does yes it does
because we can hook up because we can
hook up two people because we can hook
up two people two machines and can track
their brain activities during them
having a dream
having anxiety having certain feelings
we can actually track their brain
activities we can see when it works we
can see when it stops working we can see
when it turns off when it turns on we
can track all these things due to 21st
century science and neuroscience due to
psychological research and neuroscience
something that alidawah knows nothing
about you cannot smell you cannot yeah
or real consciousness really can you do
the same with energy for example how
much
can you do the same with with all the
energy in the uh that
you can put it under a specific screen
and track it you idiot that's how it
works this is science
this is science i am asking you to
demonstrate to me
i'm asking you to demonstrate to me how
consciousness has to be there in order
to bring it into existence
you're an absolute ignorance what kind
of a teacher are you studying these
books
engage with the actual argument okay
engage with the actual argument come on
respond to me respond to the necessary
being
do you want to have a discussion or not
let me finish this question do you want
to have a discussion or not you have
been talking forever and cutting me off
do you will you let me talk or not i'll
cut you off everyone can see will you
let me talk or not everyone can see that
you don't let me talk to william
you asked me a question about the
necessity of being being personal and
i'm telling you so let me tell you if
you're asking me a question let me
answer so that's what i'm saying if it's
independent it gave rise to these
dependent things does that not require
will
can you prove it can you can you show me
how that how that exactly works okay you
demonstrate it okay yeah okay so this
there's dependent things
there's many dependent things in our
universe yeah the independent necessary
being has to have a will it has to will
it because they're dependent on what it
can't be infinite even amount of
dependent things they require the
necessary being to give rise to it so
the national being requires a will to
will it
the will has nothing to do with it being
a necessary being it is
it is in no part
uh in no way part of the argument
well
the will
the will of the originator is in no way
part of the actual argument do you have
somebody there who can actually help
help help you with that they will say
the same thing whether that being has a
will or not has nothing to do with the
argument here at all you are talking
about something you know nothing about
open a book go to school stop driving
your taxi go to college if you want to
talk about these things educate yourself
read a book open a book learn something
about it you're talking nonsense a
whether a necessary being has a will or
a consciousness or not has nothing to do
at all with an argument from contingency
or from a necessary being that's not how
it works at all and even your dear
friends your sabor ahmed or mohammed job
i could get william craig here i could
ask him to review this and he will laugh
his ass off listening to your reasoning
here despite the fact that he agrees
that there is a creator you have no clue
what you're talking about you idiot you
have the iq of a bird come to come to
the actual discussion you are talking
about things you know nothing about and
embarrassing yourself while trying to
humiliate me and everybody's seeing it
people are laughing at you man you are
so embarrassing you are so damn
embarrassing on this topic you should
stop it get back to islam tell me where
the sun goes at night tell me how allah
comes to the lowest heaven at night tell
me how
how the sun and the moon chase each
other all the time tell me how the moon
will lose its light which doesn't even
have light tell me why muhammad said the
sun goes at sunset to ask for permission
to rise again and one day it will not be
given permission and go back to its uh
to its to its resting place and rise
from the west explain that to me where
does the sun go talk about relevant
things nobody cares about your idiotic
stupid understanding of theology you are
embarrassing yourself entirely
people are laughing at you i know you're
you're acting like you're completely
cool right now you're acting like you're
you you've already done something right
now people are laughing at you man
people are embarrassed of you muslims
are watching and feel embarrassed with
you i have tons of messages of muslims
saying alidawah please don't embarrass
us please don't do this i can prove it i
i sent you messages yesterday i sent
alidawah messages yesterday at least 15
messages 30 messages of muslims saying
aridawa brother please don't embarrass
us please don't do this you know this
you know i told you this you know i did
that and you know that you then turned
off because you were uncomfortable by
that isn't that right
talk about things that you actually
claim to know something about like islam
and answer to me where the sun goes at
night come on let me know
yeah you are come on you let it all out
at home you are a dumb idiot you have an
iq of 90 or 85 or something i don't know
okay go ahead oh yeah i am the one who's
doing that dominance come on come on
answer the question where does the sun
go at night carry on
where does the sun go at night
anxiety embarrassment humiliation
uh i would say in all honesty i am
frustrated by the fact that such an
imbecile like you claims to have some
knowledge yeah recovery
acceptance is a good step to recovery
i accept that you are an imbecile yes
come on answer the question stability
instability you can't even spell the
word animals stop talking about things
oh how intelligent what a great what a
great concept we don't even know how to
spell the word would you want to brag
about a word you don't even know how to
spell it anyways you're finished
oh yeah how do you spell dynamics can
you can you spell personal mysteries let
me get this right i've got the yeah of
course i am the i am the one who says
people should be killed for what i'm not
believing i listen to you let me finish
it okay i'm gonna answer my question
where does the sun go at night if i
listen to you let me finish where does
the sun go at night you had the tantrum
you went on a mad one where does the sun
go when you get angry you do this
where does the sun go at night what's
this why i keep doing this i know you're
uncomfortable where does it go
it's burning
you don't even know what it means which
is what you're doing right now come on
and i love that
where does the sun go
where does the sun go
that's why you're doing this i know you
i know your body where does the sun go
at night gamepl
know uh mubarak
with an atheist you're fooled oh yeah i
don't know anyway
where does the sun go at night i've
listened to you let me talk where does
the sun go at night i'm not going to
engage with your arguments any further
you made arguments i i encourage you to
use this argument go ahead where does
the sun go don't get angry yeah don't
even leave your business as soon as you
talk about something different i will
cut you you invent you spend some time
with your family you clown you're going
depressed in your little house and you
got keyboard
anyways i
said and let me talk okay
i have what is this
let me speak man i didn't speak i know
you don't talk about irrelevant things
people on patreon are going to say bro
this guy is a liability to us yeah sure
i'm seeing them right now this guy's the
stupidest guy ever but anyway shut the
[ __ ] up where does the sun go at night
that's my question boy your little boy
where does the sun go at night
intellectually i'm an uber driver
i'm proud earning a halal living yeah
okay maybe some of your followers are
uber drivers yeah i'm an uber driver who
has iq of a bird okay i haven't got a
degree apparently i haven't read books
but i smashed you
yeah
where does the sun go at night
mohammed says the son goes to his
resting place at night and comes back in
the morning again
where does the sun go at night have a
will where does the sun go at night
what's my question
where does the sun go
would you marry off your little daughter
at the age of 6
where man was 50 years old you're
insecure i'm proud of you like this
shoulder do you think this looks like
insecure okay i'm talking to a pedophile
worshiper what do you think would you
would you marry off your little little
daughter at the age of six
perverted profit at the age of 55. yes
would you do that
would you do it
now
would you marry of your little daughter
at the age of six to a man who is 55
years old would you do that i'll smash
you on that what do you do you go there
just just answer my question come on i
don't care about you necessarily you
have no clue what you're talking about
at least at least i don't agree that i
will have intimacy with my own child i
would i don't i don't either
at least i don't believe i don't either
necrophilia is okay okay demonstrate to
me where where did we agree that we
would discuss your arguments today in my
own blood my own child my own family
sent your video to me when i said this
to him he wanted to vomit i said this
guy believes and i said the video of
amin you saying there is nothing wrong
with incest you said to me if there is
no harm you will have intimacy with your
own child you disgusting person i never
i never said that you are i never said
that custom person i never said that
i never said that
your prophet was a pedophile the purpose
is that true
where does the sun go at night if you
don't want to talk normally i will talk
like this where does the sun go
up we're going to meta ethics
where does the sun go at night i'll step
you up little boy yeah you don't even
know what i think what does mata ethics
mean
what is the etymology
okay i know your position okay i know no
you don't you just said i believe in
error theory i never said that where did
i say it yes listen listen you said you
do not be very good or bad i can go
there and stop you up there as well
that's not that's not aries that is not
everything no no no no no
another thing another thing where you
say you can educate me and you have no
idea what you're talking about because
you say it's not bad there is no okay
is that is that necessarily error theory
you fool and your phone
okay answer my question answer my
question is that necessarily area theory
you cannot come and say this is good
this is bad you feel even your friend
david wood said that to you waste man he
said to you how could you talk about the
issue of aisha's marriage if you believe
in that you [ __ ] you dumb your own
friends can i ask you what can i ask can
i ask one question
i can ask you one question you can't
mention ash's marriage to the prophet
now anymore you fool your own friend
mocks you they call you apus they mock
you april's and david wood refuted you
david wood made a point for islam he
said how could you question isis
marriage when you don't believe in that
okay anyways funny can the minister you
don't have a will okay since you made it
since you made the argument since you
made the claim
if somebody says there is no good and no
evil does that mean they believe in
everything
oh yeah well you're a [ __ ] you're
running away right now
by your own words you call people [ __ ]
that's what you want
and penetrated her
[Music]
[Music]
there
three lines three lines next to
childhood no you know sort of culture
you coward you don't even know free
verses you muted me you idiot i'm trying
to i mute myself what okay can you use
that solar counter
i'm not sure i'm not reciting anything
waste man
when did we agree to debate your topic
why do you not want your debate
a little hute
you're a wasteman look i'll open it for
you you read it i don't care what i
don't know you need it i don't care what
it is like you open it i'll read it
where does the sun go at night
come does allah come down it's the time
of the night to the lowest heaven
pray to me you're finished
you're finished there we go read this
read this can you read it
read it read it read it
can you read it can you bring it closer
where does the song go at night read it
read it i'll beg you three lines free
lines where does the sun go at night
okay if he doesn't want to do it
no no let me send it on twitter i'm
gonna send you on twitter let me send it
on twitter one second if he doesn't want
to engage with it i'll just do it here
i'm gonna send it on twitter all right
sahih bukhari uh 3199. the prophet asked
me at sunset do you know where the sun
goes at the time of sunset i replied
allah is an apostle no better he said by
the way this is such an issue farid
himself didn't want to respond to this
argument
he said it goes and travels until it
prostrates itself underneath the throne
of allah and takes the permission to
rise again and it is permitted and then
it okay good so guys as you can see
and i was going to travel to us
made it easy but i exposed this fool
here can you imagine i was going to go
all the way there for this fool he ran
away from the contingency argument he
can't he thought you could do mubarak
with an atheist
okay this fool this absolute ignoramus
clown absolutely intellectually
humiliated guys alhamdulillah after
daniel smashed him
hijab buried them jake flipping
intellectually brought him back and
slapped him up again and then you had a
little girl and then lastly who did you
have a 17 year old boy intelligent boy
martial and what did hijab say hijab
said a smart sharp 16 year old boy
can deal with you and that's exactly
what happened he was 17. that's exactly
what happened brothers and sisters
these people we deal with them like
alhamdulillah you can see he couldn't
engage with argument left right center
he doesn't even know they're embarrassed
by their own religion embarrassed by
their own religion they can't answer
simple religions about their own they're
getting out there and they're answering
simple questions about their own
religion can't tell me why muhammad made
prophecies that the world would end
within a hundred years but it didn't end
why muhammad said before this boy grows
old the end will come but it didn't
happen cannot tell me
why
muhammad said
i don't know me and the day of judgment
are like this but it didn't happen
cannot tell me why muhammad said allah
comes down to the lowest heaven every
night and stays there until a certain
time to listen to our prayers which does
not work in a ground earth as we know it
right now cannot tell me why muhammad
said the sun goes to a resting place at
night cannot tell me why muhammad made
prophecies of constantinople and of rome
being conquered and then the day of
judgment being coming very soon cannot
tell me why muhammad said that the john
might be here now or that the john will
be coming very soon and 2 000 years have
passed they cannot tell any of these
things they don't want to talk about
these things because they are
embarrassed about their religion which
is why this guy has to sit here and list
insults and discuss about theology when
he doesn't even understand it i mean
have you listened to this guy's uh
contingency argument it is the dumbest
thing that i've ever heard he doesn't
know what he's talking about he admits
of to have to never having read a book
on this topic and wants to educate
people who actually talk about these
things and actually read about these
things and you know discuss about these
things it is so stupid
it's very clear from here why this guy
did not want to have a debate which is
why he made this setup he is not willing
to have a debate but he's willing to sit
here with me for two hours and just
insult me for no proper reason while
also advocating for killing me and
apostates like me in his ideal islamic
state and then saying that people like
me have blood on our hands and even if i
asked him today alidawah if you are
brave enough answer this question if you
could turn the uk into an islamic state
where people should be executed for
apostasy would you do it yes or no
i finished the tantrum yes would you do
it yes or no answer okay good okay okay
good yeah if you could turn the uk into
an islamic state where people are
executed for apostasy would you do it
yes or no one second
okay are you finished your tantrum have
you let the anger answer my question
answer my question i don't care do this
do this answer my question come on look
breathe in through your mouth
answer my question hold it five seconds
yes or no you have five seconds and then
you go from the nose two yeah okay three
four
five okay you have to answer the
question fantastic so another question
that he doesn't want to answer another
question that he's too cowardly to
answer he's too cowardly to take a
vaccine to come to america and says that
i was scared of facing an idiot an
imbecile like him can you believe that
can you believe that he's scared of
taking a vaccine and wants to avoid the
debate based on that
he probably has the vaccine he probably
just makes it up as an excuse because he
doesn't want to have a debate
he follows a pedophile prophet
cannot discuss because he has openly
said he is on record saying she would
marry his daughter off finish to an old
man boy if she is ready at the age of
nine
he actually said he would marry off his
nine-year-old daughter to an old man if
it were possible he said that we have it
on video we have it on record he did say
that his friend mohammad hijab said that
the quran actually allows child marriage
and having sex with five years old this
is islam and he's too shy to admit this
here right now he's too shy to admit
these things because his religion would
work
while it is life
yeah go ahead
you're a coward you're a coward go ahead
people have seen you today fantastic
that was better than the debate no you
can't [ __ ] off i don't care
bro